okay six one seven eight three zero
4750 let's go to our next caller from
the nine one six area code caller from
nine one six go ahead hey David um I've
got two questions um the first one is do
you ever foresee in any future that the
world would operate under a singular
government
I do not okay and then the second
question being if that's the case how do
we ever get to any kind of utopian state
where there is no war famine etc we
probably will not get there that's
terrible
now listen I mean I'm kidding by giving
you just you know these are such complex
questions and the answers are obviously
much more more complicated no I mean
okay so I don't believe that we're
eventually going to see a one-world
government without commenting on whether
it's a good or bad idea and I think that
there would be things that would be
easier under a one-world government and
things that would be very very difficult
and complex under a one-world government
I don't think we're going to get there
and I think that you know if the goal is
utopia I think the goal shouldn't be
utopia the thing we already have too
complex of a world to say that the next
step is utopia I think we need to like
more critically examine systems that are
working and systems that are not working
and trying to improve upon them and I'm
not giving you like Ted Kennedy
incrementalist BS right but what I am
saying is that given where we are it's
just not going to be realistic or
productive to say the next step is this
utopia it's lovely to think about it
would be great to think about a world
where we eliminate famine and we get
climate change under control and we is
that on the case what is the best
solution at least as far as the endgame
for civilization then III think that
that question I can't possibly even
conceive of the question as it's fully
being asked let me answer it in a more
intermediate way I think in the
immediate
what we're learning is that the best way
to organize our society
socioeconomically based on the options
we currently have on the planet is
social democracy in the style of the
Scandinavian and Nordic countries with
more community run or shared ownership
within individual businesses that want
to put that in place I think that that
should be sort of a medium term goal to
go towards would that still apply with
automation taking over the work industry
absolutely absolutely I think it would
be even more important and the ideas
listen universal basic income is not I
mean Finland which already is a social
democracy is testing universal basic
income and I think that ubi is not that
far of a throw from the social democracy
model so I think that that is the best
MOT one of the best equipped models of
what we currently have if we want to
deal with inequality and lack of access
to resources cool thank you all right
thank you really appreciate the call
today's episode of the programme is made
possible in part by Coins schedule which
is a listing site for cryptocurrency
icos
that's been around since 2016 it was
actually one of the first websites to
show helpful listing information about
icos you can look i ciose up by name
industry the end date the start date and
coin schedule gives each IC o---- a
score using an algorithm based on dozens
of parameters that help determine how
trustworthy an IC o---- is for example
whether or not the identities of the IC
o---- team have been verified whether
the IC o---- has a white paper and other
factors like those they don't try to
make predictions about the long-term
success or failure of an IC o---- often
that's actually impossible to do what
coin schedule does is provide users with
a combined score of how much operational
risk there is four different IC o---- so
that you can know where to be extra
careful when you see a low rate
if you're watching on YouTube I've put a
link to the coin schedule website at the
top of the video description nothing in
coin schedule should be considered
personalized investment advice I cos are
risky people should do their own
research and make their own decisions